This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing evidence-based results-driven treatment for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28. Newport treats clients who are struggling with mental health conditions, co-occurring disorders, and issues like toxic perfectionism. Newport's outpatient and residential programs around the country provide supportive, caring environments where adolescents and young adults can be their authentic selves without needing to be perfect. Learn more at Newport Healthcare.com. Are you the type of person for whom good is never good enough? At first glance, perfectionism might sound like a minor hurdle to overcome, or even a positive personality trait. After all, what's wrong with wanting to excel?
本期节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，他们为12至28岁的青少年和年轻人提供基于证据、以结果为导向的治疗。Newport致力于帮助那些正在与心理健康状况、共病以及有毒完美主义等问题作斗争的客户。Newport在全国各地的门诊和住院项目提供支持性、关怀性的环境，让青少年和年轻人能够展现真实的自我，而无需追求完美。欲了解更多信息，请访问Newport Healthcare.com。你是那种觉得“好”永远不够好的人吗？乍一看，完美主义听起来可能只是一个需要克服的小障碍，甚至是一种积极的人格特质。毕竟，想要追求卓越有什么错呢？
But perfectionism is different from simply striving for excellence, and perfectionistic people are at higher risk for anxiety, depression, and other mental health disorders. So what's the difference between being a perfectionist and just being a high achiever? Where does perfectionism come from? Is it innate or learned? How does perfectionism affect people's physical and mental health? What's the difference between expecting perfection from yourself and expecting it from others?
但完美主义与单纯追求卓越不同，完美主义者患焦虑症、抑郁症和其他心理健康疾病的风险更高。那么，完美主义者和单纯的高成就者之间有什么区别？完美主义从何而来？它是天生的还是后天习得的？完美主义如何影响人们的身心健康？对自己期望完美和对他人期望完美有什么区别？
And if you, your child or someone else close to you, struggles with perfectionism, what can you do to help? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological. Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. We have two guests today. First is Dr. Bonnie Zucker, who is author of A Perfectionist Guide to Not Being Perfect, published in February by APA's Magination Press imprint. The book aims to help teens and their families understand perfectionism and learn strategies
如果你、你的孩子或你身边的其他人正在与完美主义作斗争，你能做些什么来提供帮助？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是主持人金·米尔斯。今天我们有两位嘉宾。第一位是邦妮·扎克博士，她是《完美主义者的非完美指南》一书的作者，该书由美国心理学会旗下的Magination Press于二月出版。这本书旨在帮助青少年及其家庭理解完美主义并学习应对策略。
to cope with it. Dr. Zucker is a licensed clinical psychologist and private practice in Rockville, Maryland. She has a particular expertise in treating stress, anxiety, and anxiety-related disorders. In addition to her new book, Dr. Zucker has written several previous books that aim to help children and families, including anxiety-free kids, and take control of OCD, the ultimate guide for kids with OCD. Our second guest is Dr. Gordon Flett. Dr. Flett is a professor in the Department of Psychology at York University in Toronto, where he holds a Canada Research Chair in personality and health. Dr. Flett is also author of a new book published by the American Psychological Association called Perfectionism in Childhood and Adolescence, a developmental approach. Together with his collaborator, Paul Hewitt, Dr. Flett has spent more than three decades studying
扎克博士是一位持证临床心理学家，在马里兰州罗克维尔市设有私人诊所。她在治疗压力、焦虑和焦虑相关障碍方面拥有特别的专业知识。除了这本新书，扎克博士还撰写了多本旨在帮助儿童和家庭的书籍，包括《无焦虑的孩子》和《掌控强迫症：儿童强迫症终极指南》。我们的第二位嘉宾是戈登·弗莱特博士。弗莱特博士是多伦多约克大学心理学系的教授，在那里他担任人格与健康领域的加拿大研究主席。弗莱特博士也是美国心理学会出版的新书《童年与青春期的完美主义：一种发展视角》的作者。与他的合作者保罗·休伊特一起，弗莱特博士花了三十多年时间研究
perfectionism, including how to measure it, how perfectionism is associated with depression, anxiety, and other disorders, and the role of perfectionism in physical illness. Thank you both for joining us today. Thank you, Kim. Thank you. I'm thrilled to be here. So I mentioned in the introduction that people often confuse perfectionism with simply striving for excellence. What is the difference between the two? How is perfectionism different from just working hard and striving to excel?
完美主义，包括如何衡量它，完美主义如何与抑郁、焦虑和其他疾病相关联，以及完美主义在躯体疾病中的作用。感谢两位今天加入我们的节目。谢谢你，金。谢谢。我很高兴能来到这里。我在介绍中提到，人们经常把完美主义与单纯追求卓越混为一谈。这两者之间有什么区别？完美主义与仅仅努力工作和追求卓越有何不同？
And Dr. Flett, let's start with you. Sure, thanks for that. It's a key distinction. People are perfectionists, they're all or none thinkers who want absolute perfection. Falling short might even be more frustrating than falling way short for them. So they need to be absolutely perfect. A big difference between someone who's a perfectionist and somebody striving for excellence is, are they satisfied? The person striving for excellence is more likely to be happy with what they've done.
弗莱特博士，我们先从您开始吧。好的，谢谢。这是一个关键的区别。完美主义者是“非黑即白”的思考者，他们想要绝对的完美。对他们来说，达不到目标可能比远远达不到目标更令人沮丧。所以他们必须做到绝对完美。完美主义者和追求卓越者之间的一个巨大区别在于：他们是否感到满足？追求卓越的人更有可能对自己所做的事情感到高兴。
But the extreme perfectionist usually is never satisfied, even when there's a great accomplishment or achievement. So it's just on to the next attempt rather than basking in any satisfaction that might have been experienced. Are we seeing an uptick in the number of people who struggle with perfectionism, especially among younger kids and teenagers? There have been a lot of articles recently about the hyper-competitive youth culture in the U.S. And how kids have to have perfect grades and star in multiple sports and all of those things to get into college. Dr. Zucker, does this track with what you're seeing in your practice? Absolutely.
但极端的完美主义者通常永远不会满足，即使取得了巨大的成就。所以他们只会进行下一次尝试，而不是沉浸在可能已经获得的任何满足感中。我们是否看到越来越多的人在与完美主义作斗争，尤其是在年幼的孩子和青少年中？最近有很多关于美国过度竞争的青年文化的文章。孩子们必须拥有完美的成绩，在多项运动中表现出色，才能进入大学。扎克博士，这与您在诊所中观察到的情况一致吗？绝对一致。
And I often wonder why, because I have kids saying to me, well, you know, I have a have to have a thing in high school in order to get into college. So I'm figuring out what my thing is. I said, oh, what kind of thing do you mean? Well, you know, I need to have something either a sport or photography or, you know, I have to do something. That's my thing. And I feel that the pressure that we see coming from social media, the image of success and needing to do college is just a launch, you know, the idea that you have to go to graduate school if you want to do anything meaningful. The bar is just so high. And then there's this belief that I have to go to a really elite college or a prestigious college in order to have a successful future, which we know is
我经常想知道为什么，因为有孩子对我说：“你知道，我必须在高中时有一项‘特长’才能进入大学。所以我正在弄清楚我的特长是什么。”我说：“哦，你说的特长是指什么？”“嗯，你知道，我需要有一些东西，要么是运动，要么是摄影，或者，你知道，我必须做点什么。那就是我的特长。”我觉得我们从社交媒体上看到的压力，那种成功的形象和必须上大学才算起步的观念，你知道，那种如果你想做任何有意义的事情就必须读研究生的想法。门槛实在是太高了。而且还有一种信念，认为我必须进入一所非常精英或著名的大学才能拥有成功的未来，我们知道这
all untrue. But that's the stereotype that's really being portrayed that I think kids are absorbing. And so we are, I am definitely seeing more perfectionism and also around body image and appearance, which is where I think the social media plays a role. Dr. Flood, is there research into the prevalence of perfectionism? And if so, is there an upswing? Yes, there is. And it certainly fits with the observations that Pani's shared with us. We have a summary in our book of 10 studies that look at prevalence of different types of perfectionism. And alarmingly, across the 10 studies, it looks like one out of three adolescents have some form of perfectionism that puts them at risk. And we also cite some other data, some survey data, one study done in Canada, over 24,000
完全是不真实的。但这确实是被描绘出来的刻板印象，我认为孩子们正在吸收这些。所以，我确实看到了更多的完美主义，也看到了围绕身体形象和外貌的完美主义，我认为社交媒体在其中发挥了作用。弗莱特博士，是否有关于完美主义流行程度的研究？如果有，是否呈上升趋势？是的，确实有。这当然符合邦妮与我们分享的观察结果。我们在书中总结了10项研究，这些研究着眼于不同类型完美主义的流行程度。令人担忧的是，在这10项研究中，看起来每三个青少年中就有一个患有某种形式的完美主义，这使他们处于风险之中。我们还引用了一些其他数据，一些调查数据，一项在加拿大进行的研究，超过24,000名
high school students, and over half of them indicate that they're feeling some pressure in terms of expectations to be perfect. And of course, the worry there is that it suggests that the pressure is now normative if it's more than 50 percent, but also how do you define perfect? You know, it's so subjective. So, you know, the adolescent who really is not certain is somebody who's going to define perfect at an extreme level and is going to feel intense pressure, even if they don't take on those standards themselves, they're going to feel that others are expecting them to be perfect. Let's talk for a minute about the role of social media. Another common refrain is that social media encourages people to compare themselves to a false, perfect-seeming vision of other people. people's lives. Do you think that's the case and is social media harmful to people who are
高中生中，超过一半的人表示他们在追求完美的期望方面感到压力。当然，令人担忧的是，如果比例超过50%，这表明这种压力现在已经成为常态，但你如何定义完美呢？你知道，这太主观了。所以，你知道，那个真正不确定的青少年会把完美定义在一个极端的水平上，并会感到巨大的压力，即使他们自己没有接受这些标准，他们也会觉得别人期望他们变得完美。让我们谈谈社交媒体的作用。另一个常见的说法是，社交媒体鼓励人们将自己与他人生活中虚假的、看似完美的愿景进行比较。你认为情况是这样吗？社交媒体对那些
struggling with perfectionism? Well, I certainly see it in terms of the research that we've been conducting. We study a concept called perfectionistic self-presentation. And one way that it's really expressed is online with people with these crafted perfect lives that nobody actually has. And unfortunately, if you're on social media and you're susceptible to these cues, you're going to be bombarding yourself with images of how others are doing. And it's not just comparing now with how you did on a test or on a paper or whatever, but now it's the life. Are you having the perfect life? And there's a lot of ways that you can make yourself feel very badly about this. And general advice is for any young person or anybody not to do too much of this because there's
正在与完美主义作斗争的人有害吗？嗯，我当然从我们一直在进行的研究中看到了这一点。我们研究一个概念，叫做“完美主义的自我呈现”。它真正表现出来的一种方式是在网上，人们展示那些实际上没人拥有的精心打造的完美生活。不幸的是，如果你在社交媒体上，并且容易受到这些线索的影响，你就会用别人做得如何的图像来轰炸自己。现在这不仅仅是比较你在考试或论文中做得如何，而是关于生活。你是否拥有完美的生活？有很多方法可以让你对此感到非常糟糕。一般的建议是，对于任何年轻人或任何人来说，不要做太多这样的事情，因为
no way that you can feel really good about yourself in the long run. Dr. Zucker, is that what you're seeing in your practice? And do you tell young people in particular to stay off of social media? I actually encourage them to have a healthy relationship with social media. And I love, Gord, what you said about crafted, because I always explain to kids, you know, this is constructed. Social media, it's our constructed view that we want to portray. And people don't post themselves when they're struggling or when they have a bad day or
从长远来看，你不可能对自己感觉良好。扎克博士，这是你在诊所中看到的情况吗？你是否特别告诉年轻人远离社交媒体？我实际上鼓励他们与社交媒体建立健康的关系。戈德，我很喜欢你说的“精心打造”这个词，因为我总是向孩子们解释，你知道，这是构建出来的。社交媒体是我们想要展示的构建出来的视角。人们不会在他们挣扎或度过糟糕的一天或
they don't look good. They only post themselves often with filters, looking their, absolute best, living their best life. And so we teach kids, this is constructed. It's not real. And we have to have a healthy relationship with it. So perfectionists often have an obsessive style. They're very detail oriented. And that's their approach to looking at social media as well. When they look at other people's pages, they're really taking it all in. And so I do encourage a healthy social media diet where you limit the amount of time. some days you don't even go on it. You notice how you feel when you're on it. And Kim earlier
看起来不好时发布自己的照片。他们发布自己时通常会使用滤镜，展示他们绝对最好的一面，过着他们最好的生活。所以我们教孩子们，这是构建出来的。这不是真实的。我们必须与它建立健康的关系。所以完美主义者通常有一种强迫性的风格。他们非常注重细节。这也是他们看待社交媒体的方式。当他们看别人的页面时，他们真的全盘吸收了。所以我确实鼓励一种健康的社交媒体饮食，限制使用时间。有些日子你甚至不去碰它。你会注意到当你使用它时的感受。金刚才
said something about comparisons. And I really encourage teens and younger children as well to have relative comparisons versus normative ones. Normative is when we compare ourselves to other people. Relative is when we compare ourselves relative to us. So how am I feeling about myself this week compared to last week? How did I do in my math test this week compared to last week as opposed to How did I do compared to the top student? Where does this drive for perfection come from? Are some people born perfectionists, or do they learn this trade, or is it some combination? Definitely, it's a combination.
提到了比较。我确实鼓励青少年和更小的孩子进行相对比较，而不是规范性比较。规范性比较是指我们将自己与他人进行比较。相对比较是指我们将自己与自己进行比较。所以我这周对自己感觉如何，与上周相比？我这周数学考试做得怎么样，与上周相比？而不是：我与尖子生相比做得怎么样？这种对完美的驱动力从何而来？有些人是天生的完美主义者，还是他们学会了这种特质，或者这是某种组合？绝对是某种组合。
And a key thing to realize right from the start is that two kids could both be perfectionist, but have got there in very different routes depending on what their experiences are in the family. So there is a role. Typically, the historical view was to focus on. parents do a lot of parent blaming or even just imitating a parent. But also, of course, that could mean that there's a genetic element to the perfectionism in the family. And the six or seven studies done on that indicate that there is a heritable component to it. But then, of course, with most things, we realize that there's also environmental factors. And we've already talked
从一开始就要意识到的一件关键事情是，两个孩子可能都是完美主义者，但根据他们在家庭中的经历，他们走上了非常不同的道路。所以这确实有作用。通常，历史观点倾向于关注父母，进行大量的“责怪父母”或仅仅是模仿父母。但当然，这也可能意味着家庭中的完美主义存在遗传因素。对此进行的六七项研究表明，它确实存在遗传成分。但当然，对于大多数事情，我们意识到也存在环境因素。我们已经谈到了
about social media and the pressure. A big thing would be the peer environment, if you're hyper-competitive if peers are expressing the need to be perfect, you feel the need to keep up. And then, you know, broader socio-cultural factors in terms of belief that certain countries or certain areas of the United States, for instance, have more of a focus on perfectionism, such as in Utah and in Mormon culture. At the end of the day, though, the question is, does the person internalize it in terms of how they see themselves and are they judging themselves according to needing to be perfect, or are they seeing it just imposed externally?
社交媒体和压力。一个很大的因素是同伴环境，如果你处于过度竞争的环境中，如果同伴表达了对完美的需要，你就会感到需要跟上。然后，你知道，更广泛的社会文化因素，即认为某些国家或美国某些地区，例如在犹他州和摩门教文化中，对完美主义的关注更多。然而，归根结底，问题在于，这个人是否在看待自己的方式上将其内化了，他们是在根据需要变得完美来评判自己，还是仅仅将其视为外部强加的？
And as I reiterate, that how you get to be perfectionistic could be very different in terms of the roots. One subset of thinking about this is that some people are experiencing adverse life experiences. So they try to be perfect as a way of coping as a sort of very defensive orientation. And when somebody says, well, there might be a positive side to perfectionism. Not for these people. They're just trying to manage what's ever going on and thinking that if I'm perfect, whatever's happening will stop happening. So they are very concerned about trying to establish a sense of control over what's going on in
正如我重申的那样，你如何变得完美主义在根源上可能非常不同。关于这一点的一个思考子集是，有些人正在经历不利的生活经历。所以他们试图变得完美作为一种应对方式，作为一种非常防御性的取向。当有人说，嗯，完美主义可能有一个积极的一面。对这些人来说并非如此。他们只是试图管理正在发生的任何事情，并认为如果我变得完美，无论发生什么都会停止发生。所以他们非常关心试图在他们的
their daily lives. Dr. Zucker is focusing in on parents, one of your strategies? And is that kind of where you start? Or do you start with the young people themselves? So I start with the young people themselves. And I want to know what their perspective is on their family. And so I really take it from them in terms of, is everyone in their family an MD or an MD PhD? Right.
日常生活中建立一种控制感。扎克博士，关注父母是你的策略之一吗？这是你开始的地方吗？还是你从年轻人自己开始？所以我从年轻人自己开始。我想知道他们对家庭的看法。所以我真的从他们那里了解，比如，他们家里每个人都是医学博士或医学博士/哲学博士吗？对。
Because even if the parent, which we, in Montgomery County, which is where I practice, you know, we have a lot of high achieving families. And that achievement orientation is, in fact, the book over Achievers is written about the students at one of our local high schools, Whitman High School. And I want to hear from the kids because sometimes the parents. are not really doing anything wrong, but it's just who the parents are and the life they're living that, again, goes back to setting this bar really high. And in those cases, too, I want to find out from the parents are how are they responding. Most of the time the parents are responding just right and they notice the perfectionism. They're bringing the child in to help them be less perfectionistic. They don't want their child to be burdened. And then every now and then, though, I do get a really
因为即使是父母，我们在蒙哥马利县（我执业的地方），你知道，我们有很多高成就的家庭。这种成就导向，事实上，那本《过度成就者》就是关于我们当地一所高中——惠特曼高中的学生写的。我想听听孩子们的想法，因为有时父母并没有真正做错什么，但这只是父母是谁以及他们所过的生活，这又回到了把门槛设得非常高的问题上。在这些情况下，我也想从父母那里了解他们的反应。大多数时候，父母的反应恰到好处，他们注意到了完美主义。他们带孩子来是为了帮助他们减少完美主义。他们不希望孩子背负负担。然后，虽然偶尔，我确实会遇到一个非常
perfectionistic parent. Sometimes they're aware, sometimes they're not. I had a parent respond to her daughter proudly telling me that she got five A's and two Bs on her report card with, well, it could have been seven A's. And I said, can I meet with your mom, just your mom and I for a minute? I said, do you know the message? What was your intention? She says, my intention was I want her to know that if she put a little more effort into those, that she really could be a straight A student. I said, what do you think the impact was? She's like, well, I assume it wasn't good since we're meeting alone. And I fell in love with the mom at that moment, right, that I could have this dialogue with her.
完美主义的父母。有时他们意识到，有时他们没有。我有一位母亲，当她的女儿自豪地告诉我她在成绩单上得了五个A和两个B时，她回应说：“嗯，本可以是七个A。”我说：“我能和你妈妈单独谈谈吗，就你妈妈和我？”我说：“你知道传达的信息吗？你的意图是什么？”她说：“我的意图是我希望她知道，如果她在那些科目上多花点努力，她真的可以成为全A学生。”我说：“你认为影响是什么？”她说：“嗯，我假设不太好，因为我们正在单独会面。”那一刻我爱上了这位母亲，对吧，我可以和她进行这种对话。
I said, the impact was, it's not good enough. That's the messaging there. So sometimes you get really well-intentioned parents, you know, thinking they're enforcing one thing. And unfortunately, reinforce something else. So those corrections, if you have an open system, you can make great strides in giving better messaging. Is this obsession with perfection more prevalent in American culture? Dr. Flett, do you see it as much among Canadians because that's where you are or other countries, other cultures? It's really a worldwide phenomenon from what we can tell. I mean, research is being done around the world, a lot of research in Europe and Asia. And it just seems to be a problem worldwide and one that seems to be growing based on indicators of one that.
我说：“影响是，这还不够好。这就是传达的信息。”所以有时你会遇到非常有心的父母，你知道，认为他们在强化一件事。但不幸的是，强化了别的东西。所以那些纠正，如果你有一个开放的系统，你可以在提供更好的信息方面取得巨大进步。这种对完美的痴迷在美国文化中更普遍吗？弗莱特博士，你在加拿大人中，或者其他国家、其他文化中，看到的程度一样吗？从我们所能了解的情况来看，这确实是一个全球性的现象。我的意思是，世界各地都在进行研究，在欧洲和亚洲有很多研究。这似乎是一个全球性的问题，而且根据指标来看，它似乎正在增长。
of the studies that I was referring to in terms of prevalence was a study of almost a thousand high school students in Australia, where they were assessed with multiple measures. And again, we're talking at least one out of three having some form of maladaptive perfectionism. I think what needs to be looked at is the interpretation culturally about what perfection means. I think that varies substantially. And we still need some sound research on what does perfection mean, but the pressures are pretty much seemingly universal. And this was shown in a study that looked at about 110 different symptoms, and it was done with 27, 30 cultures in this data set. And the item that had to do with the pressure to be perfect came out in the top 10 out of
我提到的关于流行程度的研究之一是对澳大利亚近一千名高中生进行的研究，他们接受了多种评估。同样，我们谈论的是至少三分之一的人患有某种形式的适应不良的完美主义。我认为需要审视的是关于完美意味着什么的文化解读。我认为这有很大差异。我们仍然需要一些关于“完美意味着什么”的扎实研究，但压力似乎在很大程度上是普遍的。这在一项研究中得到了证明，该研究着眼于大约110种不同的症状，并且是在这个数据集中的27到30种文化中完成的。与追求完美的压力有关的项目出现在了前10名中，
110 indicators based on data from gathered around the world. And regardless of whether you're asking the actual children or their parents or their teacher. So that pressure seems to be very ubiquitous. This episode is sponsored by Newport Healthcare, delivering accessible and ethical treatment to young people ages 12 to 28 who are struggling with mental health conditions and behavioral issues. Newport's integrated whole person approach addresses the underlying trauma that can lead to depression, PTSD, and substance abuse, as well as issues like toxic perfectionism and high-functioning anxiety. With outpatient residential programs for teens and young adults, Newport provides tailored treatment
基于从世界各地收集的数据的110个指标。无论你是询问实际的孩子、他们的父母还是他们的老师。所以这种压力似乎非常普遍。本期节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，为12至28岁正在与心理健康状况和行为问题作斗争的年轻人提供可及且合乎道德的治疗。Newport的综合全人方法解决了可能导致抑郁、创伤后应激障碍和药物滥用，以及有毒完美主义和高功能焦虑等问题的潜在创伤。通过针对青少年和年轻人的门诊住院项目，Newport提供量身定制的治疗
plans designed for each client's individual needs and history. Young people learn how mistakes and so-called failures can help them become stronger and more resilient. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. How is perfectionism associated with mental health disorders such as anxiety and depression? Dr. Zucker, in your practice, do you? you see these things going together often? I do. And I am pretty much limited to seeing people with anxiety disorders and OCD and related
计划，旨在满足每个客户的个人需求和历史。年轻人学习错误和所谓的失败如何能帮助他们变得更强大、更有韧性。欲了解更多信息，请访问newporthealthcare.com。完美主义与焦虑和抑郁等心理健康障碍有何关联？扎克博士，在你的诊所里，你是否经常看到这些问题同时出现？是的。而且我基本上仅限于看患有焦虑症、强迫症和相关
conditions. So I might be a little bit of a biased sample, but often I am treating someone with anxiety. And we learn that at the root is really perfectionism. And when you look at the research, and I know Dr. Flett would be even better to share this, it's very clear that perfectionism causes anxiety, depression, eating disorders, and suicidality. And it goes back to how Dr. Flett started with this all or nothing thinking. I either need to be completely perfect and get that 100 or I've failed. And also, I noticed I was reading your book, Dr. Fled, and in the beginning you talk about the sense of self. And that's something I speak about constantly in my practice because when I'm working with teenagers, they are figuring out who they are. There's that, that whole Eric Erickson
疾病的人。所以我可能是一个稍微有偏见的样本，但我经常治疗患有焦虑症的人。我们了解到，根源确实是完美主义。当你查看研究时，我知道弗莱特博士会更擅长分享这一点，很明显，完美主义会导致焦虑、抑郁、饮食失调和自杀倾向。这回到了弗莱特博士开始时提到的这种“非黑即白”的思维。我要么需要完全完美并得到那个100分，要么我就失败了。而且，我也注意到我正在读你的书，弗莱特博士，在开头你谈到了自我感。这是我在诊所里经常谈论的事情，因为当我与青少年一起工作时，他们正在弄清楚他们是谁。有那个，整个埃里克·埃里克森的
identity versus role confusion. That's the phase they're in. And we want their identity to be about who they are, not about what they're accomplishing. What they accomplish can be a part of it, but it can't be the whole story. And so when you're a perfectionistic, your accomplishments and your achievements become your identity. So there's not much wiggle room. And that's where you see the depression. It's where you see the anxiety. It's very challenging. So more objectively then, Dr. Flett, do you see these connections? Is that what shows up in the research, the connection between anxiety and these other disorders and perfectionism? And to what degree? It's moderate to high. And one of the things that we say, especially with things like
身份与角色混乱。那是他们所处的阶段。我们希望他们的身份是关于他们是谁，而不是关于他们正在完成什么。他们完成的事情可以是其中的一部分，但不能是全部。所以当你是一个完美主义者时，你的成就和成绩就变成了你的身份。所以没有太多的回旋余地。这就是你看到抑郁的地方。这就是你看到焦虑的地方。这非常有挑战性。那么更客观地说，弗莱特博士，你看到了这些联系吗？研究中显示的是焦虑和其他障碍与完美主义之间的联系吗？程度如何？是中等到高。我们所说的一件事，特别是像
meta-analytic results indicating the length between perfectionism and suicide is that these research studies are done focusing on variables, but ultimately we're concerned about people. And the problem is that perfectionism is associated when you look at it at the person level with a host of other vulnerability and risk factors that in the one individual sort of as a confluence of heightened risks. So for instance, the suicidal adolescent who is perfectionistic is also likely to put on the front, they're overrepresented sadly among suicides where people say nobody saw it coming. The planfulness of perfectionism then turns out to be not so adaptive because of,
元分析结果显示完美主义与自杀之间的联系时，这些研究侧重于变量，但最终我们关心的是人。问题在于，当你从个人层面来看时，完美主义与许多其他脆弱性和风险因素相关联，这些因素在个体身上形成了一种高度风险的汇合。例如，有完美主义倾向的自杀青少年也可能表现出一种外表，他们不幸地在自杀者中比例过高，人们会说没人预见到这一点。完美主义的计划性结果证明并非那么具有适应性，因为
and we know about how methods are perfected really. And again, it's the all or none approach. And say there's a particular risk if there's been a past attempt because of the concern that perfectionists have with failure and shame. But the research certainly bears this out. And this is both cross-sectionally and longitudinally. But when I try to think of research studies, as my colleague Paul Hewitt, we try to take the person focus and think, okay, how can we study this? Because at the end of the day, it's about safeguarding people and getting them to help.
我们知道方法是如何被真正“完善”的。同样，这是“非黑即白”的方法。如果曾经有过尝试，会有特别的风险，因为完美主义者对失败和羞耻的担忧。但研究确实证实了这一点。这既是横向的也是纵向的。但当我试图思考研究时，作为我的同事保罗·休伊特，我们试图采取以人为本的方法并思考，好吧，我们如何研究这个？因为归根结底，这是关于保护人们并让他们获得帮助。
And we're particularly concerned about this tendency to hide behind a front. Perfectionists, I think, have a great deal of loneliness and sense of isolation, not realizing that other kids are feeling the exact same way. And they tend to see that something about them as if they're defective. yet we really need to start asking what kind of society we have and highlighting the societal pressure so that it's not seen as a personal defect or shortcoming. It's a pressure that everybody's having trouble dealing with. I mentioned in the intro the difference between expecting perfection from yourself and expecting it from others. Dr. Fleck, can you talk about the different forms of perfectionism? Sure, glad too.
我们特别担心这种躲在面具后面的倾向。我认为完美主义者有很大的孤独感和孤立感，没有意识到其他孩子也有同样的感觉。他们倾向于认为自己有什么缺陷。然而，我们真的需要开始询问我们拥有什么样的社会，并强调社会压力，这样它就不会被视为个人的缺陷或缺点。这是一种每个人都在努力应对的压力。我在介绍中提到了对自己期望完美和对他人期望完美之间的区别。弗莱特博士，你能谈谈完美主义的不同形式吗？当然，很高兴。
Well, we have talked about perfectionism as multidimensional. Most people talk about self-oriented, which is pushing yourself and demanding it from yourself, but you can also demand it from other people, which is a problem, of course, because that tends to lead to conflict and people not wanting to be around you. And that's called other-oriented. The flip side of that is probably the worst form, and that's called socially prescribed. That's the perception that others expect or demand. perfection from you.
嗯，我们已经谈到了完美主义是多维的。大多数人谈论的是“自我导向”，即推动自己并对自己提出要求，但你也可以对其他人提出要求，这当然是一个问题，因为它往往会导致冲突和人们不想和你在一起。这被称为“他人导向”。其反面可能是最糟糕的形式，被称为“社会规定”。这是指感知到他人期望或要求
And socially prescribed perfectionism might be veritical. You might actually have people like that in your lives or in a role where you're expected to be perfect. But often it's a way of viewing the world and being sensitive to these cues. And then, of course, we talk about the self-presentational part that I've talked about. Another element that is important to think about in terms of that front versus what's going on inside is we also measure the cognitions that deal with perfectionism. And perfectionists might seem calm and incapable and in control on the outside,
你变得完美。社会规定的完美主义可能是真实的。你的生活中可能确实有这样的人，或者处于一个被期望变得完美的角色中。但通常这是一种看待世界的方式，并且对这些线索很敏感。然后，当然，我们谈到了我提到的自我呈现部分。在考虑那种面具与内心发生的事情之间的关系时，另一个重要的因素是，我们也衡量处理完美主义的认知。完美主义者在外面可能看起来冷静、有能力且能掌控一切，
but in the inside they're having a barrage of these negative thoughts about themselves and negative thoughts about not being perfect. And we measure this with a scale call a perfectionism cognition inventory. And this is why we think it's very important for people to reach out to somebody who's a struggling perfectionist, but only on the inside. we want to make sure that they know that people are concerned about how they're doing in terms of their emotions and their feelings and they're not suppressing them trying to live up to this image. Dr. Zucker, how do you treat the people who come to your practice who have perfectionistic
但在内心深处，他们对自己有大量的负面想法，以及关于不完美的负面想法。我们用一个叫做“完美主义认知量表”的量表来衡量这一点。这就是为什么我们认为人们向那些内心挣扎的完美主义者伸出援手非常重要。我们想确保他们知道人们关心他们的情绪和感受，而不是让他们压抑这些感受，试图活出这个形象。扎克博士，你如何治疗那些来到你的诊所并有完美主义
tendencies? Okay, that's my favorite question so far. So, of course, I use cognitive behavioral therapy, which is the most empirically supported approach to treating perfectionism. The concept here is we definitely have to look at the thoughts like the all or nothing, catastrophizing, shoulds, shoulds is I, you know, I should be doing this perfectly or I shouldn't make mistakes. So we look at thinking errors. We look at cognitive schemas, my sense of how I see myself, others in the world. We change the person's self-talk so they can say things like I must face my fears to overcome them. What would someone who's not perfectionistic think in this situation, what would they do? But the crux of it is really the behavioral exposures. So I create these
倾向的人？好的，这是目前为止我最喜欢的问题。所以，当然，我使用认知行为疗法，这是治疗完美主义最受实证支持的方法。这里的概念是我们绝对必须审视那些想法，比如“非黑即白”、灾难化、“应该”。“应该”就是我，你知道，我应该完美地做这件事，或者我不应该犯错。所以我们审视思维错误。我们审视认知图式，我如何看待自己、他人和世界的感官。我们改变一个人的自我对话，这样他们就可以说出诸如“我必须面对我的恐惧才能克服它们”之类的话。一个非完美主义者在这种情况下会怎么想，他们会怎么做？但其核心确实是行为暴露。所以我创建了这些
ladders. I literally draw it out like a ladder with rungs where we come up with anywhere from 10 to 20 exposures or practices that the child or teen does to challenge their perfectionism. So you are changing the behavior with the expectation that the thoughts will change after. So for example, we make a mistake. We purposely answer in math class the wrong answer. So you have the person exposed themselves to their fears. I had a girl I worked with who I just was crazy about. And I said, you know, you're straight A. You have to get a B on one of your math tests. And she said, this is terrible therapy. I don't want to come back here. Why would you tell me to fail in school? I said, well, first of all, I didn't say fail. I said get a B. And I did say in school.
阶梯。我字面上把它画成一个有梯级的梯子，我们想出10到20个暴露练习，让孩子或青少年去做，以挑战他们的完美主义。所以你是在改变行为，并期望想法会在之后改变。例如，我们犯一个错误。我们故意在数学课上回答错误的答案。所以你让那个人暴露在他们的恐惧中。我曾与一个我非常喜欢的女孩一起工作。我说：“你知道，你是全A。你必须在一次数学考试中得一个B。”她说：“这真是糟糕的治疗。我不想再来这里了。你为什么要告诉我学校考试不及格？”我说：“好吧，首先，我没说不及格。我说得一个B。”我确实说是在学校。
I said on a test. So she and I negotiated that she would hand in homework late one day. And in her class, if you handed in late one day, you would get knocked down. Of course, she was getting an A, so she's supposed to get a B, right? So she and I talk about this for weeks. We finally decide she's going to do it. And she goes to school and she says to her teacher, you know, I'm sorry, I don't have my homework. I'm going to have it to you for tomorrow. And the teacher says, is everything okay? And she says, no, everything's fine. I just, I had some other things going on. And she said, everything's okay at home. She says, yes.
我说是在考试中。所以她和我协商，她会有一天迟交作业。在她的班级里，如果你迟交一天，你的分数就会被扣掉。当然，她本来是得A的，所以她应该得一个B，对吧？所以她和我谈论这个谈了几个星期。我们最终决定她要这样做。她去学校对老师说：“你知道，我很抱歉，我没带作业。我明天会交给你。”老师说：“一切都好吗？”她说：“不，一切都好。我只是，我还有其他事情要处理。”老师说：“家里一切都好吗？”她说：“是的。”
She goes, well, don't worry. Just bring it in tomorrow. You'll still get the A. Because the teacher's expectation. She loved the girl and wanted her to achieve. And so anyway, we had to do it again. And she came back and she said, this teacher's going to think my parents are getting a divorce or something.
老师说：“好吧，别担心。明天带过来就行了。你还是会得A。”因为老师的期望。她喜欢这个女孩，希望她取得成就。所以无论如何，我们不得不再次这样做。她回来后说：“这个老师会以为我父母要离婚什么的。”
I said, I know you've got to get the B. So anyway, she did it the following week. And the teacher said, I, you know, I'm surprised this is happening again. But I think it'd be unfair. if I didn't drop you down to a B, she goes, no, that's okay. I think it's good for me to get a B every now and then, you know? So it really helped. She still got an A in her class. She still had straight A's in her report card, but she had to go outside of her comfort zone, right? We have to teach kids that they can go outside of their comfort zone and tolerate the discomfort. When you
我说：“我知道，你必须得那个B。”所以无论如何，她在接下来的一周做了。老师说：“我，你知道，我很惊讶这又发生了。但我认为如果我不把你降到B是不公平的。”她说：“不，没关系。我认为偶尔得一个B对我来说是好事，你知道？”所以这真的很有帮助。她在班上还是得了A。她的成绩单上还是全A，但她不得不走出舒适区，对吧？我们必须教孩子们，他们可以走出舒适区并忍受不适。当你
tolerate the discomfort, you build up that resilience. And then you understand people still like you. You could still be happy. You know, you have to actually experience it differently. in order to think differently about it. So it's a behavioral exposure approach. Dr. Flett, what does the research say about effective treatments for perfectionism? Well, it's complicated, and I don't want to contravene Bonnie because I think she hit the nail on the head in multiple ways. But one of the things we talk about in our book and my colleague really is championed
忍受不适时，你就建立了那种韧性。然后你明白人们仍然喜欢你。你仍然可以快乐。你知道，你必须真正以不同的方式体验它，才能以不同的方式思考它。所以这是一种行为暴露方法。弗莱特博士，研究对完美主义的有效治疗方法有什么说法？嗯，这很复杂，我不想反驳邦妮，因为我认为她在多个方面都说到了点子上。但我们在书中谈到的一件事，我的同事确实支持
is taking a more relational approach to the treatment of perfectionism. And we've got some interesting results from a controlled study that's currently under review, not with kids, but with adults. And, you know, part of the interpersonal model that looks at other oriented perfectionism and socially prescribed takes into account that sometimes perfectionism is driven by interpersonal needs. One I'm focusing on is the need to matter to other people. And one of the ways that you can cope with a sense of not mattering or not mattering enough is to try to be absolutely perfect, you know, sort of if I'm perfect, now I'll be on the radar. are now we'll get the love and respect. So our approach, we tend to advocate more of an
采取一种更具关系性的方法来治疗完美主义。我们从一项目前正在审查中的对照研究中得到了一些有趣的结果，不是针对孩子，而是针对成年人。而且，你知道，着眼于他人导向完美主义和社会规定完美主义的人际模型的一部分考虑到了完美主义有时是由人际需求驱动的。我关注的一个是“对他人重要”的需求。应对一种不重要或不够重要的感觉的方法之一就是试图变得绝对完美，你知道，某种程度上，如果我完美了，现在我就会出现在雷达上。现在我们就会得到爱和尊重。所以我们的方法，我们倾向于提倡更多的人际关注，
interpersonal focus where we're getting at that, which reflects more of the, you know, psychoanalytic object relations approach. And, you know, but again, it comes back to how and why is somebody a perfectionist, you know, perhaps it's driven by needs that are well suited at cognitive behavior therapy. And in the cases of where it might actually be the case that somebody does have a demanding parent, for instance, or somebody who's really got some toxic expectations, it's about managing how to get through that relationship and not internalize the negativity. And the negativity usually comes in intense criticism that is directed right at the self in a way that makes people, again, feel inadequate or not worthy. So, you know,
我们正在触及这一点，这更多地反映了精神分析客体关系方法。而且，你知道，但同样，它回到了一个人为什么是完美主义者的问题上，你知道，也许它是由认知行为疗法非常适合的需求驱动的。在某些情况下，确实有人有要求苛刻的父母，或者确实有一些有毒期望的人，这是关于管理如何度过那种关系，而不是内化消极情绪。消极情绪通常以直接针对自我的强烈批评形式出现，使人们再次感到不足或不值得。所以，你知道，
so I guess the message here is that it depends really on what, what is at the root of the perfectionism. And also, when somebody actually has a life setting where they have to be perfect, here we'd be talking about adults, but, you know, it's very important with somebody with a high-stressed job where they're not allowed to make a mistake to learn how to keep it focused on the workplace and not internalize that and generalize that in terms of interactions on the home front. So if you're an air traffic controller, for example, you can't make any mistakes on your job, but you can make mistakes elsewhere in your life. Yes, you want to land that plane.
所以我猜这里的信息是，这确实取决于完美主义的根源是什么。而且，当某人确实处于必须完美的生活环境中时，这里我们谈论的是成年人，但是，你知道，对于一个不允许犯错的高压工作的人来说，学习如何将其集中在工作场所，而不是内化并将其推广到家庭前线的互动中是非常重要的。所以如果你是一名空中交通管制员，例如，你在工作中不能犯任何错误，但你可以在生活的其他地方犯错误。是的，你想让那架飞机着陆。
So what can parents or adults do themselves if they sense that they're, you know, tending toward perfectionism that is maybe becoming a problem? What advice do you give folks, Dr. Zucker? And you're talking about adults who are experiencing their own perfectionism, not necessarily models as parents. Could go either way. All right. So in general, I always encourage parents to,
那么，如果父母或成年人感觉到他们，你知道，倾向于可能正在成为问题的完美主义，他们自己能做些什么？你给人们什么建议，扎克博士？你谈论的是正在经历自己完美主义的成年人，不一定是作为父母的榜样。可能是双向的。好的。所以总的来说，我总是鼓励父母
model making mistakes and to put words to times when they're not doing their best. So, for example, sometimes I might be rushed and stressed and I'm sort of barking at everyone. And I try not to have these moments often. But when I do, I'll say, you can tell I'm really stressed, right? And you can see, I'm not handling myself well right now, right? You know, and so I think when parents say I messed up or I didn't handle that well. They're modeling that it's okay to make mistakes. And to say things like we don't need to be perfect. And then to mirror their child,
示范犯错，并为他们没有尽力的时候用语言表达出来。例如，有时我可能会匆忙和压力大，我有点对每个人大喊大叫。我尽量不经常有这些时刻。但当我这样做时，我会说：“你可以看出我压力很大，对吧？你可以看到，我现在处理得不好，对吧？”你知道，所以我认为当父母说“我搞砸了”或“我处理得不好”时。他们是在示范犯错是可以的。并说出诸如“我们不需要完美”之类的话。然后去镜像他们的孩子，
which does actually highlight what Gorge just said about the relational part, to mirror their child for who they are and to say, you're not perfect and I love you. And the who of you, right, the person in there, the you of you, which is always there is someone I love. and it has nothing to do with your performance. So I do think we have to be modeling that, expressing that. And then for the adult, who is just on their own perfectionist,
这实际上确实突出了戈德刚才所说的关于关系的部分，去镜像他们的孩子是谁，并说：“你不完美，但我爱你。”以及你的“谁”，对吧，里面的那个人，你的“你”，它一直都在，是我爱的人。这与你的表现无关。所以我确实认为我们必须示范这一点，表达这一点。然后对于那个只是自己完美主义者的成年人，
they need to do the same approaches. I don't treat kids and adults all that differently. I do ladders for them. In fact, they're more passionate sometimes about putting star stickers on their ladder than some of the kids I see. They're like, get your stars out. You ready? You know, because we, I'm working with an adult now with perfectionism.
他们需要做同样的方法。我对待孩子和成年人的方式并没有那么大的不同。我为他们做阶梯。事实上，他们有时比我看到的一些孩子更热衷于在他们的阶梯上贴星星贴纸。他们说：“把你的星星拿出来。准备好了吗？”你知道，因为我们，我正在和一个有完美主义的成年人一起工作。
who is very frustrated all the time that people in her life at work and also socially are not doing things in the way she would do them. They're not on time, right? So I'm having her practice things like showing up late herself and being apologetic, getting there super early so it feels like someone's late even when they're on time, really getting comfortable, again, stepping outside of our comfort zone and recognizing the value of meeting. with colleagues and with friends is to get along with them and to be productive. And that that's not compromised even if the meeting starts 20 minutes late. So it's getting them to shift their perspective, but again, going back to these exposures.
她总是对生活和工作中周围的人没有按照她的方式做事感到非常沮丧。他们不准时，对吧？所以我让她练习一些事情，比如自己迟到并表示歉意，或者早早到达，这样即使别人准时到达，她也会觉得别人迟到了。这真的是为了让她感到舒适，再次走出舒适区，并认识到与同事和朋友会面的价值在于与他们相处融洽并提高效率。即使会议迟到了20分钟，这一点也不会受到影响。所以这是让他们转变观念，但还是要回到这些暴露疗法上。
People love the exposures. They really build confidence as well. So last question, Dr. Flett, what's next on the research front? I mean, you've been looking at this issue for 30 years. What's their left to look for? That's the thing. There's always something more to look at. And it's part of the problem.
人们喜欢暴露疗法。它们确实也能建立自信。最后一个问题，弗莱特博士，研究方面接下来要做什么？我的意思是，你研究这个问题已经30年了。还有什么值得研究的吗？这就是问题所在。总有更多的事情需要研究。这也是问题的一部分。
And fortunately, we have researchers around the world who are setting up new ideas all the time. Great work on developmental trajectories and how kids may not stay at the same level of perfectionism as they get older. But we currently have two papers under review with some great work by my former postdoc, Danielle Mulnar, who's at Brock University in St. Catharines, Ontario, looking at kids in the pandemic who are perfectionistic and some fabulous work that they've done there to show. show the struggles. And it's really intriguing because this is the first full-scale qualitative examination of perfectionistic kids. And one thing we've learned just as an illustration is that, you know, we say in our book, well, you know, maybe if you're heightened awareness and they realize the cost and the consequences, these kids almost to every single one of them are well aware
幸运的是，世界各地的研究人员一直在提出新的想法。关于发展轨迹以及孩子们随着年龄增长可能不会保持在同一完美主义水平的研究非常出色。但我们目前有两篇论文正在审阅中，其中包含我以前的博士后丹妮尔·穆尔纳（Danielle Mulnar）的一些出色工作，她在安大略省圣凯瑟琳斯的布鲁克大学工作，研究疫情期间具有完美主义倾向的孩子，他们所做的一些极好的工作展示了这些挣扎。这非常引人入胜，因为这是对完美主义儿童进行的第一次全面的定性检查。作为一个例子，我们学到的一件事是，你知道，我们在书中说，嗯，你知道，也许如果你提高了意识，他们意识到代价和后果，这些孩子几乎每个人都非常清楚
that perfectionism is a problem. They're well aware of the fact that it's costing them in variety of ways and might lead to mental health issues or physical health issues, but they can't stop because they're afraid of what's going to happen if they do stop. It's sort of like, yeah, I know it's a problem, but if I stop this, what's next, you know, in terms of what the world has for me. So we're learning things new all the time. And I think that that again illustrates the importance of focusing on the individual person and really trying to fashion research that will help us capture what they're telling us
完美主义是一个问题。他们非常清楚这在很多方面让他们付出了代价，并可能导致心理健康或身体健康问题，但他们无法停止，因为他们害怕如果停止会发生什么。这就像是，是的，我知道这是一个问题，但如果我停止这样做，接下来会发生什么，你知道，就世界对我而言意味着什么而言。所以我们一直在学习新的东西。我认为这再次说明了关注个人并真正尝试制定研究方案的重要性，这将有助于我们捕捉他们告诉我们的内容
and showing us as a source of just trying to understand them better. Well, I want to thank you both for joining us today. This has been really illuminating. I appreciate you. You came at it from slightly different vantage points, and I think they were both really, really useful. Thank you. Thank you so much.
并向我们展示，作为试图更好地理解他们的一种方式。好吧，我要感谢你们两位今天加入我们。这真的很有启发性。我很感激你们。你们从稍微不同的角度来看待这个问题，我认为它们都非常有益。谢谢。非常感谢。
Yes, thanks very much, Kim. And great, great speaking to Bonnie. You've got to do this again sometime. I know. I want to do it again now. Thank you so much. It's wonderful. Well, thank you again.
是的，非常感谢，金。和邦妮交谈真是太棒了。你们一定要找时间再做一次。我知道。我现在就想再做一次。非常感谢。太棒了。好吧，再次感谢。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you listen on Apple and you like what you hear, please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condyenne.
您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您在 Apple 上收听并且喜欢您所听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果您对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至 SpeakingofPsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩（Chris Condyenne）。
Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的收听。我是美国心理学会的金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。